horizon forbidden west has had an
interesting development cycle on the
brink of next-gen gaming while it's
being released for the playstation 5
gorilla games says they did most of
their development on the playstation 4's
hardware so if you haven't been able to
snag a ps5 just yet don't worry gorilla
games says the ps4 version will not be a
compromise way to enjoy your journey
through the forbidden west so sit back
and enjoy our comparison of ps4 vs ps5
gameplay on performance mode if you're
excited for horizon forbidden west make
sure to subscribe to gamespot for more
videos like our review combat tips and
more
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
the savior of meridian
anointed of the nora you know i hate
being called that stuff well consider it
a punishment for running out on us the
very same night we beat hades
i grew up an outcast remember i'm not
much for parties
yeah
that one was in your honor
just saying
these plants don't look like the ones in
the sacred lands the focus helps you see
the ones we need
get to the grass
see how parts of it are glowing
[Music]
huh
cuts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the shuttle's caught up in those cables
i'm gonna have to climb the tower to
find a way to disconnect them
so
[Music]
[Music]
you